I wanted to start with talking about
modeling and there are a lot of
beautiful people on the on this planet
and there are many people who go into
modeling and they're very very few who
get to where you are and it strikes me
that there are some it would seem
success cases of in this case women who
have gone off to build incredible
businesses like Kathy Ireland and there
are others so I wanted to start with
asking you if you had when you were
getting started or even now any role
models among women who or men who have
have gone from modeling to do other
things I mean you certainly mentioned
one Kathy Ireland there's a long list
you know Cindy Crawford Christy
Turlington Giselle many women who are in
the industry and have used their
platform or voice or or experiences to
build businesses or to make meaningful
impact in the world in whatever way
they're passionate about and like for me
that is that is success and and I I
don't know yeah I did not anticipate
working in fashion or being a model but
I recognized somewhere along the line
that there's so much more you can do
with it and the women who have come
before me certainly have proved that
it's it seems like from the outside
looking in that much like say
entertainment the machinery of fashion
and beauty and so on probably has a lot
of casualties meaning it just chews up
and spits out a lot of people there's
really high it would seem to be a
turnover a lot of turnover yeah what
were some of the key decisions that you
and or your family or people like
managers made that helped you to
navigate to avoid some of the most
common pitfalls maybe you could just
start with like what is what are some of
the most common mistakes and pitfalls
sure I mean honestly Tim I feel like I'm
living my
version of a Cinderella story or an
American dream I mean I have been able
to travel the world and have been able
to learn from the most extraordinary
people I'm sitting here with you talking
I mean this is I feel like I'm living a
dream every day and and you know I
certainly did not anticipate going into
fashion or being a model I had a very
different kind of career path in mind
and I I had this opportunity and I and I
took it what was the what was the
opportunity so I was you grew up in the
Midwest I grew up in the Midwest and my
father's a doctor he's an emergency room
physician one of the most hard-working
people you'll ever meet and so selfless
and I have three sisters and my mom's an
artist and so I just like grew up this
in this amazing Midwestern picturesque
kind of childhood and at 13 I was
stopped in a mall and asked if I would
be interested in walking in a fashion
show at the time not only did I not care
about I it just wasn't my life fashion I
mean I didn't even subscribe to
magazines I I was focusing on school I
was focusing on ballet academics and and
sports and and so anyway this idea of
modeling was like totally not even in my
in my in my mind and so I didn't I
didn't enter this with the ambition of
building a career in modeling I I was
stopped in a mall at 13 walked in a
local charity fashion show to raise
money for a local family whose my
friend's father her had her dad had
cancer so it was this charity benefit
and I was I was there were Scouts there
from real agencies and they took my name
and said let's stay in touch
I grew a couple inches fast forward to
when I'm 15 and I tell ru 15 at 15 oh my
god I was 15 years old and 511 yeah it's
painful
so we're gonna 5/9 I'm 40 look I'm gonna
get there I I believe in you I believe
in yo and so anyway so it was 15 years
old and I got this opportunity to go to
New York for the weekend and meet the
designers of cast of Calvin Klein and
and they booked me and and I walked in
their fashion show and it completely
kind of put me on the map as a new
up-and-coming model and I and it just
was it's been a wild ride ever since
ever since that that day in the mall
when I was stopped
you